The Geographic was never
far from my mind.
This is the first picture I ever
had published in the magazine
from a story about La Salle,
the French explorer.
We worked on Patagonian
dinosaur hunters.
These are dinosaur
footprints in Patagonia.
And then the third story I did
was more what you'd think as
aNational Geographicstory.
I skied around the
Yukon Territory with scientists
and we were studying nunataks
which are the rocky regions
that pop through the glaciers.
And we were doing a survey
of the animal life on that.
The assignments started
to come more frequently.
One year I did six assignments.
This is from a story
in Ashkelon in Israel.
This is a story from the
Battle of Trafalgar.
And... these are sea scouts
that are looking at a painting
on the wall behind me.
This is the first digital photo
I ever had in the magazine.
I worked on an impossible story
to do. It was called...
you know, "How Old Is It".
It was about how scientists
date and age the universe.
And I had a mathematician
we talked to
and he calculated that a
three-day old baby is
one-one hundred trillionth
the age of the universe.
So, my brother-in-law
is a OB-GYN in New York
he hooked me up with somebody
who just had a baby.
I shot it on the third
day, flew to California,
we were out in the desert and
we're just trying to think
of something that
was illustrated
that would make people
stop and pay attention.
I think my job quite often
is the opposite of a writer.
You know, it's... they want you
tearing through their words and
I want people to stop.
I always want people to
stop and just consider
and pay attention to things.
This is from
the Xinjiang Dynasty.
These boys had
collected river stones
and were going off
to build a wall.
I remember this
picture well because
there's a building
in the back and
I was standing at that
gas station in the back
and I saw them drive
by and it's like,
"Oh, my gosh, that's
such a good picture."
So, I took off running
down the road.
My driver was in the restroom,
so I ran down the road
and jumped on, after
a quarter mile or so
I jumped on the back
of this tractor.
And the guy driving the
tractor didn't realize
the kids didn't realize.
( audience laughter )
And I'm sitting there
and I get the camera up
and I'm shooting pictures.
I'm like, "this is great,
the light's really pretty."
And I had four frames
on my camera.
So I was like, "Argh!"
This was when I'm shooting film.
So I just slowed
down and made...
I made four pretty
good frames and
it was one of those
situations that
I'm happy and lucky
that I had this image.
Worked on a story
about Doggerland.
A land bridge,
during one of the Ice Ages
between the continent
and England.
Where the tide--
when this goes out
they can find footprints
and artifacts.
Some of these places are
finding amazing burials.
When things get covered
up by silt and water
and things like that
that's actually--
people would think that's
what destroys things
but that keeps the microbes
that are in the air away
and things are more
well preserved.
I worked on a story
on a tomb in Peru
called "Wari Tomb".
We set there and you
know they said,
"hey there might
be something here,"
and they completely
uncovered it in front of us
and it was clutching
that fabric.
It was an amazing thing to see
there's small tattoos
on the wrist and
this fits into a larger body
of work that I'm doing.
I photographed about
60 or 70 mummies.
3D printing.
3D printed gun.
You know we were technically
trying to figure out
how to capture a bullet.
And it's really complicated
because the strobes have to be
photographed at about one
one-millionth of a second
to capture a bullet coming out.
And, you know, there's no strobe
conventionally that can do that.
You'd have to go to MIT,
to the laboratory where
'Doc' Edgerton
invented the strobe.
So we were going to
do the best we could
and had these other strobes
and he fired the gun
this guy who 3D printed
this gun and it exploded.
So, the bullet was slowed down
because the barrel exploded.
So, this was the first picture
I shot on that assignment.
It was like, looking
at it on digital,
"well, that works
out pretty well."
( audience laughter )
That, uhh... happy with that.
I don't want to get near an
exploding gun anyway, so.
And this was the most
fun, doing this one.
This is a scanning
electronic microscope picture
that I shot of shark skin,
and you can see
the shape of shark skin and they
built a swimsuit based on that
and it was...
the fastest times in the world
was set using that suit.
Ultimately that suit
was outlawed because
they would throw it in the
water and it would just float
and you can't, you know,
wear a floatation device
they decided--
In the mean time
I had an assistant, who
was a college swimmer
and he was like,
"we should get the
fastest swimmer in the
world to wear this."
I'm like, "Yeah."
So, he goes, "Oh, it's
Gary Hall, he's in Florida.
I know where he swims."
So, he called and
within half an hour
Gary Hall had said yes.
So, I was like, "Really?"
So, then it was time to
figure out how to do it.
So we did a lot of testing,
we got there and tested.
Before... we were being
delayed through thunderstorms
and before Gary
got in the water
we were doing
some testing.
And this is me...
( audience laughter )
swimming. I showed Gary the
picture and I was trying to get
You know, 'cause
in my mind's eye
it was like that,
it was like--
( audience laughter )
you know, really svelte.
I said, "What do you think?"
And he said, "I think you
should keep your hips up."
( audience laughter )
This is a chart of the
Pythagorean Theorem of Light.
I have no idea what it says.
Or what it means.
But I had the opportunity
to work for a photographer
who did know what it meant.
And I learned more in
about a month from him
than I had learned in the
entirety of my career.
This is a picture I did for
a story about bog bodies
and this is every picture I shot
of this on this assignment.
I think I made
87 lighting changes
and there's 87 pictures.
And then that's the one
we ended up publishing.
Generally, in my work, I
kind of stop when I'm happy.
You know, lighting a situation,
so I kind of stop when
I think it's gonna look as
good as it's gonna look, so.
These were hard mummies
to photograph because
they are, basically,
shiny and black
so, you had different choices
on how you're gonna do it.
This is one of the mummies.
It's called the river of tar.
And that's the
location where some
of the bog bodies
were found.
In the bogs they are finding
all sorts of things.
They are finding, you know,
shoes, and that's a peat shovel.
A peat bog shovel from
about 2,500 years ago.
Each of these has an
individual story.
This is a 14-year old female
that they don't know why
she was in the bogs.
And this is the most famous,
this is the Tollund man
who had the leather
noose around his neck
and had a leather hat.
You know everybody talks
about his peaceful gaze
and the tannin,
the soil that he is in
is the thing that has made
their bodies so dark.
It's like tanning a saddle.
They absorb the
chemistry and
it's also what makes
their hair red.